today we are presenting our sixth
package of sanctions
first we are listing high-ranking
military officers and individuals who
committed war crimes in bucha
and those who are responsible for the
inhuman siege of the city of mario paul
this sends another important signal to
all perpetrators of the kremlin
we know who you are we will hold you
accountable you're not getting away with
this
second
we finally d swift spare bank
spare bank is one of the is the largest
russian bank it holds round about 37
of the whole banking sector
and we will also be swift to other major
banks in russia
by that
we hit banks that are systemically
critical to the russian financial system
and putin's ability to wage destruction
this will solidify the complete
isolation of the russian financial
sector from the global system
third
we're banning three big russian
state-owned broadcasters from our
airwaves
they will not be allowed to distribute
their content anymore in the european
union in whatever shape or form
be it on cable via satellite on the
internet or via smartphone apps
we have identified these tv channels as
mouthpieces
that amplify putin's lies and
propaganda aggressively
and we should not give them a stage
anymore to spread these lies
fourth
the kremlin relies on accountants
consultants and spin doctors from europe
and this will now stop
we're banning those services from being
provided in russian to russian companies
and my final point number five
on sanctions is oil
when the leaders met in versailles they
agreed to phase out our dependency on
russian fossil fuels
in the last sanctioned package as you
know we started with coal
today we are addressing our dependency
on russian oil and let's be clear
it will not be easy
because some member states are strongly
dependent on russian oil but we simply
have to do it
so today we will propose
to ban all russian oil from europe
this will be
this will be a complete import ban on
all russian oil seaborn and pipeline
crude and refined
we will make sure that we phase out
russian oil in an orderly fashion
so in a way that allows us and our
partners to secure alternative supply
routes and at the same time be very
careful
that we minimize the impact on the
global market
and this is why we will phase out
russian supply of crude oil within six
months
and refine products by the end of the
year
thus we maximize the pressure pressure
on russia
while at the same time and this is
important we minimize the collateral
damage to us and our partners around the
globe because to help ukraine
we have to make sure that our economy
remains strong
honourable members
with all these steps
we are depriving the russian economy
from its ability to diversify and to
modernize
putin wanted to wipe out ukraine from
the map
and he will clearly not succeed on the
contrary
ukraine has risen in bravery and in
unity
and it is his own country russia that
putin is sinking